ERIC ROBERSON: How many of you
have ever dealt with somebody
you shouldn't have been
dealing with?
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC ROBERSON: Why'd
you look at her?
He, like, turned and said,
[SILENT CLAPPING].
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC ROBERSON: What was that?
Like, I mean, first of all,
she's sitting, like, high, and
you're sitting low,
which makes it a
very awkward situation.
But when I asked the question,
he shifted his--
[PATTING THE MICROPHONE]
ERIC ROBERSON: But you
can start that one.
You can start that one.
But if you were in that
situation, I want to dedicate
it to this guy right
here who--
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC ROBERSON: What's
your name, man?
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Howard.
ERIC ROBERSON: Howard.
I went to Howard, so,
you know, yes, yes.
You went to Howard as well?
Your name is Howard.
She went to Howard.
Are you guys together, though?
Are you guys?
Hmm, yeah.
I understand.
Shouldn't have been dealing.
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC ROBERSON: OK.
It's OK.
It's cool.
It's only on tape.
Are you single?
Wow!
Howard.
You thinking, you know, if I
bring her but sit on another
level, I might could
get away with this.
What about you?
What's your name, sweetheart?
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Karen.
ERIC ROBERSON: All right,
Karen, are you single?
OK.
So Karen is single.
Howard is ha, ha,
ha, ha, ah, ha.
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC ROBERSON: OK.
All right.
Howard and Karen.
There are no accidents.
I'm going to dedicate this
song to Howard and Carol.
Karen.
Karen or Carol?
AUDIENCE: Karen.
ERIC ROBERSON: Karen.
My goal is, by the end of this
song, Howard is licking
Karen's face.
That's my goal.
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC ROBERSON: That's my goal.
OK.
[MUSIC-ERIC ROBERSON,
"DEALING"]
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC-ERIC ROBERSON,
"DEALING"]
ERIC ROBERSON: You
know this part.
I need you to sing this part.
[MUSIC-ERIC ROBERSON,
"DEALING"]
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
ERIC ROBERSON: Thank you.
Thank you.